coming from Turtle Rock Studios the same
studio behind the original left of dead
if bolt takes the four player co-op
experience and turns it on its head with
four versus one gameplay instead of
fighting off hundreds of zombies all
taking on an alien horde here there's
just one player controlled opponent for
you to tackle a giant flesh-eating and
thoroughly mean-looking monster well it
may look like there's little more to the
monster than an impressively sharp set
of teeth and some muscles you can just
as easily play a strategic stealth game
as you can an aggressive one than either
way it's a hell of a lot fun evolve will
feature different types of monster but
this charming chap here is called
Goliath as his name suggests Goliath is
no shrinking violet his physical
attributes are impressive letting him
rip boulders from the ground to hurl at
hunters at range and unleashes stream
the firing depth in his mouth she's too
evolved Goliath by eating animals and
you can make him bigger and stronger
with access to more abilities it's a
strategic decision to make though and
not only do you leave yourself
vulnerable to attack while evolving for
the discarded animal corpses and
footprints you leave make you easy prey
for a hunter there are four classes of
hunter in evolved assault trapper medic
and support each with their own set of
skills and a clearly defined role to
play within the team and you really do
need to play as a team in order to take
down the monster the balance between the
four hunter classes is impressive trying
to go it alone as any of them won't get
you very far
the assault class needs to be buffed and
healed to Landy's attacks the support
and medic classes need the offensive
firepower of assault to keep themselves
protected and they all need the skills
of the trapper to help them find and
incapacitate the monster voice chat
seems all but essential to get the most
out of the game if that balance was off
even by just a little bit then evolve
wouldn't have been nearly as fun to play
as it was this is a source of game that
people are going to tell stories about
after they're done playing four versus
one is a simple idea but the level of
depth that Turtle Rock is extracted from
the idea even in this early demo
surprised me and with more types of
monster on the way I can only see it
getting deeper a shooter it may be but
evolve is one of the most unique ideas
I've seen in a while and a well-executed
one at man definitely one to watch